[Musique]
le département de la réunion a célébré
ce vendredi 20 décembre le 171e
anniversaire de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé au musée de villèle un
travail de mémoire très important pour
le président de la collectivité
encore une fois je crois qu'il est de
notre devoir de participer à ce grand
mouvement qui consiste à élever la prise
de conscience face à cette barbarie qu
est l esclavage qui rappelons le est
toujours présent dans certaines parties
du monde
et bien ici à la réunion nous avons la
chance de diop que l'esclavagé a été
aboli il ya 170 ans un grand 20 décembre
pour clôturer cette année de
commémoration
le musée de villèle comme théâtre de ces
festivités qui ont débuté sur le site de
la chapelle pointue par un premier
hommage aux esclaves avec les voies
sacrées
je trouve que c'est formidable parce que
dans certains pays malheureusement on a
perdu un peu donc cette célébration
c'est vrai qu'une célébration qui qui
peut être festive mais qui doit être
également moment de recueillement
parce que c'est réel nommage à tous ceux
qui sont partis qui sont battus pour la
liberté qui sont partis peut-être sans
avoir vu le bout de tunnel mais le
dessin la jolie en vue le rouge tunnel
est ici serait bien de pouvoir donc vous
construit l'histoire d'un meilleur au
monde lui sur la page de cette histoire
s'il est là mais le cortège mené par le
président de la collectivité s'est
ensuite rendu au camp ma roue avant de
se diriger vers la plantation de madame
desbassyns désormais appelé musée de
l'habitation de l' esclavage classé au
titre des monuments historiques
il ya tout ce travail qui est aussi
menée par le département est accompagné
par l'état pour faire je dire de ce
domaine de villèle un futur musée de
l'habitation et de l' esclavage
donc c'est un gros travail et je puis
vous assurer que nous sommes pleinement
engagés aux côtés du conseil
départemental pour faire aboutir dans
les années qui viennent un ce projet de
musée de l'habitation et de l' esclavage
je crois que
c'est vraiment très attendu de la part
de nos concitoyens et nous serons au
rendez vous un rappel historique sous
l'oeil de la statue de madame desbassyns
dévoilé à cette occasion jusqu'à tard
dans la nuit le maloya a résonné pour
que l'histoire ne s'oublie jamais
[Musique]